عادت هذه الأم إلى
المدرسة الإعدادية متخفية في صورة
ابنتها البالغة من العمر 13 عامًا ،
هل أبدو مثل طالبة في الصف السابع لا
رائعة رائعة تبلغ من العمر 30 عامًا كيسي غارسيا
مصبوغة شعرها مدبوغ بشرتها وضعت على
نظارات كبيرة وغطاء للرأس من
مارفل كوميكس سأحصل عليه  لقد اشتعلت ، أنا
خائفة حقًا
الآن تقول أم تكساس إنها فعلت ذلك
وسجلت نفسها لتوضيح نقطة
أننا بحاجة إلى حماية أفضل في مدارسنا
بمجرد دخولها أعطت رقم
معرف مدرسة ابنتها جولي ،
تقول غارسيا إن المدير
استقبلها في الردهة ،
مرحبًا  صباح الخير ، صباح الخير ، كيف
تجد نفسك
حتى أنها حصلت على مجاملة ،
شكرًا لك وأعطاها الناس توجيهاتي
، لم أكن لأجد طريقي في فصل الرياضيات أبدًا ، لقد
رفعت ملاحظات الرياضيات الخاصة بها
، وفي الغداء في الكافتيريا كانت
تحمل الطبق الجبني الذي كانت عليه  أكل
هذه القطعة مثير للاشمئزاز ولكن في
الفترة الأخيرة من اليوم
، تم القبض علي أخيرًا ،
وطلبت منها المعلمة البقاء
بعد الفصل ونظرت إليّ
وهي تبدو وكأنك لست جولي لقد
أقلعت  خلعت قناعتي
وقلت لا لست جوليان ، أنا والدة جولي ،
لماذا سألتني المعلمة قلت أول
تجربة اجتماعية في
غضون أيام جاءت الشرطة
إلى منزلها لاعتقالها بتهمة التعدي الجنائي
والتلاعب بالحكومة
السجلات
هل أحتاج إلى أي شيء لم يتم
القبض عليّ من قبل في حياتي في
نفس اليوم الذي تم فيه إطلاق سراحها بموجب سندات ،
أصدر
مدير منطقة مدرسة سان
بيانًا للآباء يعترف
بوجود خرق للأمن ، وأريد أن
أؤكد لكم أن إجراءاتنا الأمنية
تتم مراجعة وتقييم
محامي غارسيا وتقول إنها أثبتت أن أي توم
ديك أو هاري يمكنه الذهاب إلى مدرسة عامة
ويقضي
يومًا كاملاً دون أن يتم اكتشافها.
ورقة مدرسية قد تقوم
بتسليمها ، لقد تظاهرت بكوني جني في الصف السابع في معظم CNN نيويورك